BACK TO YOU.
>> RICH EDSON DOWN AT THE
BORDER, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GRIFF: JACQUI, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS PREPARING TO
REINSTATE THE TRUMP ERA POLICY
AFTER BEING ORDERED BY THE
COURT TO DO SO.
FOR MORE ON THE BORDER,
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FROM
TEXAS, A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE, TONY
GONZALEZ.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE BORDER, I
WANT TO GIVE YOU A MOMENT, AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN, TO
REACT TO THIS TRAGIC AMBUSH ON
THE THREE TEXT TEST CONSTABLE
DEPUTIES ONE OF WHOM WE KNOW
HAS LOST THEIR LIFE THIS
MORNING.
CONGRESSMAN?
>> YEAH, NO, MY HEART GOES OUT
TO THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
HERE IN TEXAS THAT ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE.
WHAT I’D LIKE TO SEE FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND IN HIS
SPEECH SHORTLY IS THE PRESIDENT
BEING CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT
AMERICA IS BEHIND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS, AND TO BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT WE WILL
APPREHEND THE PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS AND THEY
WILL BE BROUGHT TO JUSTICE,
FULL JUSTICE AND WE WILL SEEK
THE DEATH PENALTY FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE KILLED INNOCENT
POLICE OFFICERS.
IT NEEDS TO BE THAT CLEAN A
SPEECH, YOU KNOW, THIS RHETORIC
OF ENCOURAGING ANTI-LAW
ENFORCEMENT RHETORIC TO BE
SPEWED BY DEMOCRATS IN
PARTICULAR, HAS BECOME DEADLY.
>> SUCH AN IMPORTANT POINT,
CONGRESSMAN, BECAUSE AS WE NOW
TURN THE CONVERSATION TO THE
BORDER, SO MANY OF THE AGENTS,
MEN AND WOMEN, WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK, OVERWHELMED ON THE
BORDER, FEEL SOME LOSS OF
CONFIDENCE WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION, WITH THE
DECISIONS THEY’VE MADE.
NOW, WHEN I HAVE TALKED TO
AGENTS, THEY TELL ME IF REMAIN
IN MEXICO IS REINSTATED AND THE
COURT ORDERED TO DO SO IT MAY
HELP.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> MYSELF AND MANY OF MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
PUSHING TO REINSTATE THE TRUMP
POLICIES THAT WORK, THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY WORKED.
IT’S ENCOURAGING TO SEE THIS
ADMINISTRATION START TO GO DOWN
THAT ROUTE AND WE HAVE TO HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
I’M NOT STOPPING UNTIL I SEE
THAT REINSTATED.
ON THE BORDER, THE CARTELS ARE
CONTROLLING EVERYTHING.
IT’S CHAOS.
ON THE SPACE YOU’RE SEEING THE
MIGRANT SITUATION, BUT
UNDERNEATH THE SURFACE, YOU’RE
SEEING THE DEADLY AREA NA
ENCOURAGES TERRORISM, THAT
ENCOURAGES THE CARTELS THAT ARE
VERY SOPHISTICATED.
THEY’RE WORKING WITH
CRYPTOCURRENCY.
THEY ARE EXPLOITING OUR BORDER
AT ALL LEVELS AND ALL FACETS.
IT’S NOT JUST THE MIGRANTS THAT
WE SEE ON THE SURFACE.
GRIFF: YOU WROTE AN IMPORTANT
OP-ED IN THE HILL NEWSPAPER
THIS PAST WEEK ABOUT CARTELS
AND CRYPTOCURRENCY.
IS IT YOUR VIEW THAT THE
CARTELS ARE STRONGER THAN
THEY’VE EVER BEEN AND ONLY
GROWING?
>> THESE CARTELS ARE EXTREMELY
SOPHISTICATED AND THEY POSE A
DANGER FAR MORE THAN WE’VE SEEN
ON THE SURFACE.
WE’VE SEEN THE DANGER UTILIZING
THE CRYPTOCURRENCIES AND IT’S
AN ATTACK AGAINST THE U.S.
DOLLAR.
IT’S A BATTLE THAT THE UNITED
STATES IS IN A BATTLE WITH THE
CARTELS AND THE BOTTOM LINE,
WE’RE LOSING AND IT’S UP TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NOT ONLY
TO GAIN A HOLD OF THE SOUTHERN
BORDER TO PROTECT INNOCENT
PEOPLE THAT LIVE ALONG THE
BORDER, BUT PROTECT OUR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
OTHER THINGS AS THESE CARTELS
CONTINUE TO BECOME MORE
SOPHISTICATED.
YOU KNOW, EMERGENCY INSTEAD OF
COMING OVER WITH A BACKPACK
FULL OF CASH, IMAGINE YOU COME
OVER WITH A THUMB DRIVE FILLED
WITH CRYPTOCURRENCY?
>> AS WE LOOK AT IMAGES FROM
OUR FLIGHT TEAM, LA HOYA,
TEXAS, IN THE RGV, AND HEAVIEST
AREAS AND WHERE YOU’RE NOT TOO
FAR.
I WENT THIS WEEK DOWN TO THE
KUN OF THE PANAMA, ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO THE JUNGLE, THE DENSEST
ON EARTH, WHERE WE’RE SEEING
TENS OF THOUSANDS PARTICULARLY
HAITIAN MIGRANTS COMING THROUGH
THERE.
THE CARTEL HAS A VIRTUAL
PIPELINE THAT RUNS FROM SOUTH
AMERICA ALL THE WAY ACROSS OUR
BORDER, AND YOU WERE ABLE TO
SPEAK WITH A FOREIGN MINISTER
OF PANAMA, ERICA  MOYNES,
SOMEWHAT DESPERATE, AND WHAT
DID SHE TELL YOU?
>> I MET WITH THE FOREIGN
MINISTER TWO WEEKS AGO AND SHE
WAS SOUNDING THE ALARM ON
WHAT’S HAPPENING IN PANAMA.
ONE I THINK THIS, THEY’VE
ENCOUNTERED OVER 80,000
MIGRANTS.
THERE’S MORE ON THE WAY AND
THEY’VE ENCOUNTERED MANY FOLKS
ASSOCIATED WITH TERRORISM.
ONCE AGAIN, THIS IS A DIRECT
THREAT TO THE UNITED STATES.
AND THESE FOLKS DON’T JUST
ARRIVE AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT’S HAPPENING WELL IN ADVANCE.
WHAT WE SAW IN DEL RIO WEEKS
AGO, WE WILL SEE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN UNLESS SOMETHING HAPPENS.
I APPRECIATE YOU GOING DOWN TO
THE DARIAN GAP AND COVERING IT
FIRSTHAND.
HISTORICALLY THOSE NUMBERS
AROUND 8,000 MIGRANTS PASS
THROUGH THERE A YEAR.
THAT NUMBER IS TEN TIMES AS
MUCH AND ONLY GETTING WORSE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS TO ACT
AND IT HAS TO ACT NOW.
GRIFF: IT DOES, INDEED.
WE’RE OUT OF TIME AND I’VE GOT
TO LET YOU GO.
I WAS TRYING TO FIND OUT WHEN I
GOT BACK LAST NIGHT IF ANYTHING
HAD CHANGED ON THE SPENDING
NEGOTIATIONS ON CAPITOL HILL.
JUST 10 SECONDS, DO YOU HAVE
INSIGHT WHERE WE ARE?
>> SPENDING IS OUT OF CONTROL.
WHEN YOU’RE NEGOTIATING FROM 3
AND A HALF TRILLION TO ONE
TRILLION IT’S A LOSER ALL THE
WAY AROUND.
INFLATION CONTINUES TO SPIRAL